The joe rogan experience stay.
However those two broads I live next to you,
maybe with a tall German check that was lanky and cue the short Brunette and
then there was the Chubby or check sage.
Remember the Chubby
like heroin or something with them or something.
He did everything [inaudible]
I stopped there.
Sage is the one I did like sage's father.
I one time was the rolling stones' manager and what he did for this chick was he
bought her a fucking blockbuster and Ventura blockbuster and she said,
I don't want to block.
Turned her on to heroin and she was herpes herpes.
I didn't give him no fucking herpes.
She was giving me shit about having her.
She's over there and fucking Oh,
heroin with Joey Diaz to me.
I was,
I used to lie was homeless.
So she would come to the store on Sundays.
She would come to the store on Sundays and give me pills and she would,
she was an expert in mixing.
What was that shit?
That was big year MDB,
a
ecstasy with water.
She drinking none of the other stuff.
Does
she bring it to the comedy store and I'd be hosting on Sundays and she'd give me
drinks of the GSP.
Whatever the fuck
happened.
This one off for six months.
She take HB and really go to a house.
Rogan,
I go to a house on Sundays after I'd host,
she come down,
we buy coke from Chile.
We'd go to Ralph's,
we'd do heroin,
eat her ass pills.
She has little shows at lingerie for me.
She was a hundred pounds overweight.
But this bitch
ass you want to eat?
No,
no,
no.
I didn't see it for a long time.
She started coming around to Calistoga GSP.
So one fuck Liz is a great story.
I about this.
I was thinking about staying hope on the way up here.
And uh,
our friend Mike was selling weed,
but then one time he worked at CAA and he goes,
listen,
one of the interns over to him,
he blew up.
He ended up being Whitney Houston's manager and you know,
and the tour manager and he,
he's looking for powder.
So every day they would come over and I would sell Bobby Brown and Whitney
Houston.
You know,
they would come over like $1,100 which was per diem money.
I was taking Whitney's per diem money,
right?
Every day they come over with a little white envelope and give me the per diem
money,
and I go up to the Martell cartel and I buy 14 grams of Blo,
take an eight ball out and cut it and then give it to Whitney Houston.
And they were fucking going crazy.
They,
this went on for 30 40 days,
but I couldn't snort all the blog was,
I couldn't start it.
It was just too much.
So I was giving it to Maldon Martinez,
the whole dad.
She's done.
That's the coke that killed her.
So,
okay,
I got,
I got like two ounces of bloat,
plus I snorted all this coke and I can't it no more.
What did I call him,
Marilyn?
I go Maryland,
bring the club down to the fucking store.
Right.
I'm selling coke to Whitney fucking dad picking me up at nine in the morning,
paging me on the red page or I'm coming downstairs getting in a car with them,
going to the Martell cartel to the brothers going in the house with two grams of
coke already cut in my pocket and I would just go and take rock sack,
throw the cutter and mix it up and give it right back to them in the car and
they'd be happy as shit.
They were invited me to a and m records to come party with them.
I don't party.
I was selling them.
I was getting him a half ounce and taking an eight ball out and throwing an
eight ball of cutting.
What does an eight ball?
Three and a half grams.
So I haven't done coke my entire fucking life and I don't know like a
percentage,
like what it cost.
Percentages are
sleazy that it's all cut.
No,
no,
no.
What it not go with a fucking shit like coke because someone goes,
Hey,
do you want to do a bump?
And you go,
okay,
but you don't know what he's never bought.
When you go out with Stan,
hope somebody got cokes,
he'll do coke.
He got an elephant tranquilizer.
Stan,
what was I going to go?
Joy.
We don't give a fuck.
The train's already running.
I got nowhere to be tomorrow.
Fuck it.
We're here already.
You know what?
I got to and he said he had mushrooms.
I'm like,
what the fuck you don't.
You should.
This is the cock sucker and knocks on your door with rolling papers and no weed.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I got no rule.
Like,
like a rolling papers.
Next time you bring those fucking mushrooms with you and we could have been
right here on this would have been a great fucking podcast,
not the lizard.
So I'm Robyn Whitney and Bobby Brown for a fucking month.
I'm robbing that blow every day.
I can't do it.
I can't snort it fast.
How much are they doing?
They're doing a half ounce a day.
This is why this is God,
I need this.
No,
this is [inaudible].
They're doing a half ounce a day,
which is three ounces a week.
Oh my God.
And singing.
What does that look like?
Whoa.
Announces like this.
Like,
oh I guess like a half ounce of weed.
Like they're doing,
they're doing one of those a day.
Bobby Brown,
his face twisted.
And I was getting this shit that was flaky.
So my God,
so right.
I tell Marilyn and bring the coin,
aren't they?
Aren't they feeding an entourage at this point?
Think about coke.
It's just those two.
There's only so much coke left.
All right,
you gotta go,
you gotta go.
You get to go.
Right.
So this went on,
so on Saturday and I called Marilyn Martinez.
I go,
Marilyn,
do me a favor,
bring the blow to the comedy store cause I'm just going to sell it.
And a kid after my set gives me a little Baggie with the bottom of it filled up,
like not even,
not even two lines.
And I put it in my pocket and I take it home.
When I get home,
I do it.
It's not coke,
it's crank.
So I'm on fire now.
It's three in the morning.
I'm in my house on fire.
I got the coke kit and she hasn't stopped shaking.
Sings all right,
I have the coke in the fucking car.
No I'm not.
I'm not bouncing.
I the coping the car earlier,
I always do that shit.
I have to talking in the car.
Right.
And I wouldn't bring it upstairs.
I don't like coke in my house.
I would go down and do a little bumper about five in the morning.
You would always keep it in the car and the car ride guy thing.
I don't like it was about how backer Tom,
I don't like this.
My,
I don't need to be parents,
but I don't like it in my house anyway.
I never like Copeland mine.
It's just bad.
Vital,
make it right.
I used to leave it outside on the rocks and somebody else's garage.
Then I'm a go in and do a bump and go back upstairs.
So there's one night I got to stay in the pages going off and it's sage and I
said,
fuck it.
Let me just bring the two ounces to our house a blow.
And I brought at that time,
it was like an ounce and a half and three quarters.
This bitch pick me up at six in the morning with a case of Starbucks,
coffee and Kevin,
half a gallon of the rocket.
And we went back to the house and we did that whole package of Blo Heroin Valley
Ams and Vma GSP.
How many days?
Who days just to dog day.
Afternoon.
I had to get Scott Wolfe,
uh,
Josh moves,
brother Fredo to come get me over by the directors guild.
Oh my God.
The two days I puked till Thursday.
Jesus Christ is how sick I was.
The fucking Houston's kept calling me and I'm like,
fuck you motherfuckers.
I'm out of commission.
Right.
So finally that wex week was the grammys.
This is the last time I seen them.
I don't think I told you about this last time ever.
I seen Whitney Houston.
I got a call on a Monday morning after the grammys at nine in the morning.
And they're like,
is your boy up?
He'd have to be come get me.
And they pull up to my fucking house where I live by the Yfca and it was the
manager,
Whitney Houston and Ricky Martin in the fucking back and they're all gone.
They're gone from the Grammy's that jaw,
all them jaws are fucking goal and Jack and I got in the car with them.
I drive for the Martell cocktail.
Him sitting there like,
oh,
I don't even know what drinking more.
I just looked out the window.
I was more paranoid than he was.
I got in,
bought it,
brought it back to the college.
That's the last time I fucking see that shit.
All right.
With that,
I'm looking at all these images.
Probably not fucking start defamation suits.
That's a defamation snaky fucking Martin or whatever.
It's a two story would definitely.
If it didn't fucking happen,
then it wouldn't give it up.
Lucky Martin clean and sober now.
He came out of the closet,
has got kids,
so look these opinions and stories and not a representative of the Joe Rogan.
What the fuck is,
I was actually promoting copyrighted stuff and what is the [inaudible]?
This story might think that you always,
individuals date the fucking beat.
This story's going to get on the Internet.
No,
I've never played
11 years ago he was going to say to me,
no,
you remember be bitch the fuck sing bitch.
Okay.
[inaudible]
freaks and Geeks.
Lovers and children.
What's going on ladies and gentlemen?